Okay, so in this lesson we're going to talk about gradient descent.
Gradient descent is the algorithm that almost every neural network uses to learn.
The basic idea is simple: we have a loss function that measures how wrong our model is,
and we want to make that loss as small as possible.
So we start with random weights, we compute the gradient of the loss with respect to the weights,
and the gradient tells us the direction of steepest increase.
Since we want to decrease the loss, we take a step in the opposite direction of the gradient.
The size of that step is controlled by a number called the learning rate.
If the learning rate is too big, we might overshoot the minimum and never converge.
If it's too small, training will be correct but very slow.